I sometimes wonder why the world can't
unite the way you see in movies when you
when there's an asteroid heading toward
the earth and we know it's coming in a
few years we all get together somehow
when we're about to be invaded by some
aliens the world cooperates and we have
that kind of a of an asteroid heading
toward us it's called climate change or
or global warming or global weirding
which is what some people talk about
extreme temperatures and the world is
changing and we need all to get together
on this and we don't and we don't
declare an end to business as usual the
biggest challenge at this point is for
people to realize that the next
generation is going to be living in a
very different world and if we don't get
together and do something about it are
we will be committing a great crime to
our descendants by plundering the world
and by not fixing it and we still have
time to do that but the time is running
out
said let's promote all alternatives
let's not let's not lose the chance that
maybe some good technology will will
turn out to be much more promising than
we thought we can't afford to pick
winners but in fact we've been picking
winners for years for centuries the the
US government has been we started
financing Samuel Morse's Telegraph and
ever since then we've been pouring money
into technologies aerospace helped the
computer industry grow and radio
technology and now a lot of people are
starting to realize that it's time to
pick winners we don't have the resources
to support everything and electricity
has emerged as that kind of a solution
which solves many many problems and
exists and uses existing technology we
have to put the pieces together
differently that means we don't have to
wait for breakthroughs all the
breakthroughs are welcome when they
happen but we can get started and go
very far with today's technology so
there seems now finally to be a
recognition that this is a time to
choose one one primary route for
transportation in particular and that's
electrification
it's a big question one whether we will
declare business as usual and if we did
we would say it's time to spend the
money to make this transition as rapidly
as possible some people have estimated
it would cost six hundred billion
dollars to rapidly accelerate the growth
of the electrification of transportation
that happens to be the same amount of
money we send overseas every year for
imported oil so it sounds like a lot of
money but will be way ahead of the game
if we do it and if it involves spending
a little more on electricity and if it
involves a complicated system where
people who need to drive for work are
subsidized and where we have maybe a
what's called a fee bait system where
the big heavy vehicles are highly taxed
and the more efficient vehicles are less
text there are a lot of solutions here
but we have to have the will to do it
and to say we can't be afraid of calling
for a gas tax we can't be afraid of
saying that that some some things are
going to have to change